let's go ahead like we did before you've
got two points we're gonna join them up
so we're going to have the interval a B
like so and this idea of gradient is how
steep is this line in fact with another
color if you could have drawn our out
from your head I think that's the best
plain language definition for gradient
that you can come up with how steep is
this line
this question of state this is a really
big deal but it's sort of clouded from
you out of this guy's mood why because
at the moment I've got horizontal access
which I'm calling X and a vertical axis
are pulling line by the way let me see
the most important point on the plate
which is you're already good okay so
I've got x and y but no one really knows
what x and y signify they're just places
on the axons however if x and y are
something meaningful like for example x
might be coming across might be the
passage of time and why might be
temperature how much the temperature is
at any particular time in the day when
you look at steepness what that tells
you is how one thing like temperature is
changing according to something else if
you have a look at this for example that
might be the temperature starting from
below zero and then increasing up until
this point at some time later in the day
like right now it's quite warm okay so
therefore this question to get that
wager thank you this question of the
steepness of a line tells you a whole
lot about what the situation means which
is why next year when the vast majority
of you do tuna or extension one Mouse
[Music]
just wait a few minutes when the must
return if you do that you will find but
this idea of steepness is right at the
core of this topic that we call calculus
which is literally the heart of what
tune of mathematics in extension one is
so this is a really big deal which is
while I'm going to well another way okay
now just like we did before there's a
right-angled triangle that's hidden away
to you that I haven't drawn and we're
going to put it in so that I can measure
favor do you even see where the right in
your triangle is yes
hey can you imagine it right from B
we're gonna draw a line interval down
like this and I'd love you to do the
same you can't do that but I'm going to
tell you about why I'm not and then over
here you've got this guy coming across
okay there's my right angle now we use
this before to calculate what what are
we doing with this Wrangler train we're
doing Pythagoras to work out the
distance on that hypotenuse right now we
know we know therefore that this
vertical distance right we put it into
the Pythagoras formula to get that
length what was it it's going to be in
this case to take away what ya negative
three which makes it five okay but more
generally speaking it's one of the
y-coordinates and you take away the
other one do you remember remember it
coming up inside underneath the square
root in the distance formula now when
we're talking about gradient we give
this guy a specific name we call her
rise but it's the same thing right it's
the same thing it's how far up and be
gone
right in the same way you've got this
guy down the bottom I'll just put you
over here since I'm living space rather
than y2 minus y1 it's horizontal so
therefore it's x2 minus x1 in exactly
the same way when we talk about gradient
we give it a name we call it very good
so it just as a side note put this over
to the side because it doesn't relate to
our particular conversation right now
but you know the distance formula right
distance equals and then there's square
root blah-blah-blah-blah-blah well you
can call these things if you give them
these names right you can just call that
rise squared plus run square that's the
two things that you're calculating it's
the same pieces that go into the
distance formula as the great employment
homer that's it right there
Jake yeah good question
okay now interestingly and I'm going to
throw this one first for both the
distance and for the gratefulness it
actually does not matter which one is to
and which one is 1 I'll explain why for
gradient it is in a second I wonder if
you can work it out this is look at this
one first
okay if I write down here all right
that's why two minus y one right just
suppose I like the wrong one and had
them backwards okay in this case here it
doesn't matter which way can anyone tell
me why it doesn't matter okay so it has
to do with this guy do you see this
watch what happens if we put some
numbers in here what's the number we got
here this time we got a to take away
maybe three this is five isn't it right
fine
that's the lane okay I just suppose I
did it backwards like chose the other
way around
and we wrote negative three minus two
what would you get
you would get negative fun now hold on a
second if you square it we looked at
this under service do you remember if
you're squaring he doesn't care whether
you're 5 or negative 5 you square it
they both become 25 and they there go
underneath the square root and they
simplify it does that make sense
now in the gradient formula which let's
write down now gradients which by the
way is denoted with a lowercase M rather
than G for gradient because G's usually
used for gravity lowercase M what is the
formula for gradient them in terms of
all this stuff yeah that's another very
good run and so how have you gone versus
how far you traveled horizontally which
as you've just noted over here I can put
in all the x and y's that make that
happen
y2 minus y1 there's the rise over x2
minus x1
there's the run okay after you've
written it down put your pen down for a
second I'm going to pose the question to
you that we just did over here then it
turns out because you're some where
everythings doesn't matter which one you
put first you can go on to take away
negative 3 or you can do negative 3 take
which it doesn't make a difference
because you cuz you squared right so no
big deal you lose the information about
whether it was negative or not you don't
you don't care about it in here it turns
out it also doesn't matter but there's
nothing that you squares so why does it
not matter which one you make which one
is
there is divisional obviously it's right
there at the core of the gradient
function okay the gradient formula I
should say but division does matter if
things are negative or positive
shouldn't it so I think division is
related but that's not enough just
because you're dividing it's not like
squaring screen just gets rid of all
your negative positive what's going on
okay so this is a helpful strategy that
Daniels sort of clued us into which is
when something looks on algebraically
let's just think about some numbers and
maybe the pattern will become clear
let's work out this gradient let's do it
this way first you said to me this
number
take away this number that will give me
your eyes so what I want you to do with
me is to label which one is which now so
if you said this one take away this one
which one is two in which one is one I
should say which one's Y one in which
one twenty I think this is why one isn't
it yeah and this is why - do you agree
that's how I get this one take away that
so can you label that with me this is y
2 this is y 1 that means I've got this
being X 2 and this be X 1 you okay with
that if you put that Y - can you have
that as X 1 or do you
no nada Caroline so that does matter
it's like this is the second point this
is the first point around so it's
consistent okay let's watch what happens
as we actually work out this gradient so
just as an example I've already you've
already worked out the rise and equals
five
oh [ __ ] okay what's the run it's only
three because it's four take away one
there's your X 2 minus X 1 so three I
couldn't write that as one in two thirds
but I don't need to that's fine
now let's see what happens if I do it in
Reverse if I now say let's go rather
than this take away this I'll do it
backward this one take away this one
what's the rise now minus three
sorry negative three minus two that's
the negative five right okay that's the
one that's the rise what's the run
because I'm doing it in reverse order
I'm now gonna say instead of four take
away one I'm gonna go one take away four
which is negative 3 but but hold on
that's the same thing do you see why
it's the same thing the reason why here
it doesn't matter which way you put it
is you square it he doesn't care you
square five you're sweating it into five
same deal
the reason this why this one doesn't
matter is because if you turn the top
around you also turn the bottom around
so you introduce two negatives they
cancel out the same thing so that's one
of the really nice things about the
gradient formula and the distance
formula they're kind of hard to screw up
all right you can you can make whichever
point you want a and B and you'll still
get the same answer at the end